vous allez faire un voyage
un voyage dans votre mémoire
il vous suffit de suivre ma voie
[Musique]
on est fermé je sais qu'il est tard
désolé
on attend de vous recevoir
après la montée des eaux
l arrivée de la guerre
la nostalgie est devenu un refuge
l'avenir était des plus incertains
les gens se sont plongés dans leurs
souvenirs
rien n'est plus addictif que le passé
laisse moi là bas qu'est ce mois là bas
la tournée la page fait la même chose
personne ne disparaît comme ceinture
pour savoir où elle était partie je
devais savoir d'où elle venait
puis et elles sont passées
vous pourrez tel vers lui
[Musique]
que tous étaient vraiment elle t'a
vraiment chercher
ce n'était pas mon rôle
tu es sûr que tu veux des réponses
sam est en arrêt
vous êtes un
wet elle
rection meurtre
les gens carter secret
par ce chemin
est ici mars à dîner
fait
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fermé les yeux sur tant de choses
votre machine
jusqu'où peut-elle aller
avant que l'illusion s'arrête
[Musique]
vous allez faire un voyage
il vous suffit de suivre ma voie